my leg Annapolis is a senior staff
editor for Breitbart news a speaker and
has been named the ultimate trol by the
fusion network my leg innopolis welcome
back to the show thank you so much for
having me
I'm always supposed to come back you are
the second
well maybe the parrot or them for I know
you want to be first at every time joy
generally am in fact it's better than
that I'm normally way ahead of my time
in fact I'm normally so earlier
everything that people think I'm crazy
until six months later I used to have a
guy that I wrote comedy with who used to
always say Dave were so ahead of the
curve were behind it so maybe that's
maybe that's me maybe this one's so
unpopular I don't know ya know we've had
a couple a couple repeat guests but in a
way you're sort of the most important
not that I have to inflate your ego
because I know you like that but a
tremendous amount of stuff has happened
since we had you on so you were on I
think it was the middle of October so
we're only were you know we're five or
six months away from mattress shows
getting great by the way
thank you love it and a lot has happened
in this space that we exist this
cultural libertarian space so we got a
lot to get to but let's start with
what's happening today so this morning
there was this terror attack in Brussels
at the airport and at a train station
over there it's still unfolding so right
now we're taping this it's Tuesday
afternoon here in Los Angeles so some
stuff obviously will change why don't
you just give me your your initial
thoughts on what's going on well this is
sort of what liberalism has welcomed
into Europe you know this is the excuse
making that's been made for radical
Islam which has prevented us from
fighting this problem by people who lie
about the source of these people the
news stations who refuse to accept that
you know these these attacks have
anything to do with Islam the people
who've seen Arab world won't even use
the word Muslim before it happens this
is preventing us from fixing the problem
you know this is preventing our people
from taking out of it's adequate
security precautions you know but
looking after themselves Europe now you
know welcoming in millions of people
from alien cultures whilst the
establishment refuses to accept that
these people these people's belief
systems are just dramatically
incompatible with our own and you know
the regular citizenry is being lied to
and lied about
constantly all the time about the media
on this stuff we have population that is
not able to protect itself that is not
adequately informed about the risks the
dangers of radical Islam and the problem
in Europe is that this stuff is now
happening everywhere no one is safe
anywhere in Europe is happen in Paris is
happen in London it's happening Brussels
no one is safe from this stuff and what
does it go what our politicians leap to
the Airways to say I really want to make
it clear that has nothing to do with
Islam well it does yeah it does and as a
gay man you know I'm terrified by the
prospect of mass Muslim immigration into
Europe it's one of the reasons I spend
so much time in America now I don't want
to be there anymore yes so let's back up
a little bit it's interesting that your
initial response to that is to talk
about our reaction to it rather than the
ideology you know there's nothing
surprise it's not the ideology you're
obviously nothing surprises me about
this why are we surprised that Muslims
are blowing things up that's what they
do like I don't care about that you know
like it's it's it's a horrific for the
people who who are on the receiving end
of this terrorist stuff but is anybody
surprised that Isis blew something up no
right so I'm gonna I'm gonna save you a
little of internet hate you do make a
distinction between the nominal Muslim
person the average I think that's a
Muslim that doesn't take their religion
you don't need to do this you don't need
to do me that favor no I don't care too
much for that distinction
it is not extremists it's not radical
Islamist it's not people the security
services are worried about that you know
that are the problem it is the silent
majority of Muslims who do nothing on in
the situation have no peace movement no
resistance to their own extreme elements
just like the progressive left in the
West and in 11 cases 11 countries you
and I could be killed for who we are
that's not Isis that is mainstream
Muslim culture and we are importing that
stuff into Europe by but you know in in
millions no I don't make a meaningful
distinction between these things because
I don't care I don't see any reason to
import these cultures into liberal
Western democracies I see no reason to
do it whatsoever and as Brigitte Gabriel
once very brilliantly said in any case
the peaceful majority are irrelevant it
is not the peaceful majority that blow
up buildings it is the extremists and
right now in the world all of this stuff
is coming from one culture and one
religion and I don't want it here so
what do we do about that then what mo
what do you actually do we can't
bomb these people into oblivion we don't
have technology with a radical part of
this is an ideology right how do you be
an evil ideology we don't have to
welcome 1.4 million of them into Germany
we don't have to lie to people about
what Islam is and what Muslims believe
which the press and our politicians do
all the time we don't have to intervene
in their countries where it's not
necessary where we don't need to I was
supported the Iraq war but some of the
other things we do in the Middle East
are not necessary and just drum up this
this Western hatred that you know
tonight some of what's going on has
something to do with the West right no
I'm not saying we're responsible for it
um you know nobody is yeah well I'm not
parsing out blame but you say you do see
some connection right well you would be
an idiot to deny it you know there are
you know we have been dealing with a lot
easier on the left there are a lot of it
yes you're doing okay excellent most of
them yeah see the reason I D or show you
another very few liberal get brain um
yeah and they're learning to not think
that's a compliment a lot of people say
that to me and I'm starting to think
maybe that's what it's not okay I mean
is it a compliment I don't know I mean
it puts you up to average she's got a
compliment I have no idea I've talked to
you I mean look the the problem is not
just radical Islam
the problem is Islam there are
structural problems for this religion I
mean it is incompatible with the modern
free Western liberal democracy we live
in and particularly for you and I it is
a for you and me and is also a problem
for women there are very serious
problems with Islamic culture not
Islamist you know jihadist extremism and
of course that plays itself out and it
played itself out in the streets of
Brussels and plays itself out with far
too much regularity but with Islam there
is a problem and nobody wants to talk
about it and what you tried to do
earlier to save me from myself I don't
want it because now I respect that I
don't want it because I've got to the
point where I'm thinking look the West
the West that Islam hates so much is
what has given us gay rights it has
provided that you know for women is
given women the vote it has ended
slavery which is you know not the case
everywhere everywhere in the world it
has given gay people and women all of
the rights we now enjoy there is
effective blanket equality in the West
for all of these people yeah and every
other minority - exactly importing
Muslims is going to turn the clock
back and this is what you talk about
when you when you coin a coin and
popularize this phrase regressive left
which came from this show right but you
don't go far enough
what is a regressive left means it means
it's going to take us backwards into an
era of hatred and bigotry well the left
seems to want to import Muslims by their
millions into all of our countries
that's the regressive consequence and
it's not just terrorism so what do you
think is going on with these people I
know many of these people very well I've
worked with a lot of nice people I don't
know not with me so well I don't anymore
weird I don't but this idea judge a man
by his friends you know yeah but this
ideology I mean even this morning on
Twitter as I was scrolling through all
the craziness that every time there's a
terror attack well you know you get
every you know Avenue of craziness
I saw someone a girl twenty-something a
real girl in Belgium she actually
tweeted that the the hashtag stop Islam
the hashtag itself
she said that's worse than what actually
happened that I'm not kidding no I know
but I've got thousand you see this every
time you see this every time this is the
left believes that words have power they
don't have right they think that you can
stop somebody from being homophobic by
banning the word gay from the playground
they think that you can end racism by
banning the n-word they think that if
you shape language and control culture
that you can stamp out bigotry but
that's not how it works the point of a
civilized society the point of etiquette
and a point of negotiating the world you
know around us and negotiating with
other people is to live with one another
despite our prejudices and despite our
differences the purpose of a civilized
society ought to be
to enable everybody to live together in
harmony which is why I hate what the gay
lobby does when it bullies and ridicules
christians christians aren't going away
you know you're not gonna bully
christianity out of existence you're not
gonna ridicule christianity of existence
just because BuzzFeed doesn't like
people who believe in God no rights of
society to get everybody to you know and
we were doing a good job of that you
know the West is doing a pretty good job
of that right up until we started
importing Muslims